hey guys how's it going here with Joey
hi there that's Joey that is me I'm
Justine hello
so the other day I was watching Ingrid's
video of her getting her makeup done by
Tyler Oakley and I was telling Joey how
hilarious it was music oh why don't we
write to you yeah especially since I'm
really good at makeup so I feel like me
blindfolded will be really good like I
can do it in my sleep
did you make up in your sleep on
sometimes it depends on what kind of
dream it is oh my gosh you have three
cameras we got one camera two camera
both or we get right I guess I just
start off by doing this okay Paul did so
whatever Joey does to me I'm going to do
it even worse to him on his channel yeah
I got my pretty pink headband the thing
is my head was it blindfold like metal
we've got everything in front of us
here's all of your goods am I good okay
I don't even know it what is he good
these are all open containers from my
experience you usually go for foundation
first is this it's like a pop foundation
this is it is it open its open just pump
up go home to much as haha how many
people know just not too many no more
than four okay this edge I tell you what
are you doing right now
I don't lying the foundation just the
base coat of any girls makeup how do you
think you're doing good okay next is
concealer so what you want to do is take
it and if you have any blemishes or
anything and you want to cover them up
and make them less noticeable dab a
little on your finger as well as this
concealer isn't okay that's that's a
little too much concealer let's be real
you need to conceal a lot
that's good that demon that King uh okay
now that you're concealed
we need to get some color so um you want
to go with this is this mascara I can't
tell you Oh yup it's mascara okay you
definitely want to plump up your
eyelashes
all right let's find those eyelashes for
ya
that's my eyebrow look at nose huh am i
doing it yeah wait I should pump it up
actually it's bad to go like this
because you get air pockets and it dries
out the mascara I know that I mean there
I just yeah and you want to go on an
upward motion um never devil sometimes
down actually for the bottom lashes Oh
everything I sort of know okay is I why
is it I don't know I don't know alright
look at those eyeballs why are they add
there they are
okay you want to line these oh wait
maybe this is actually eye shadow get
one for garage highs close to push too
hard okay cuz you want to line the eye
okay let's try to do no just keep going
is over my eye
okay I think we have another one this is
another eyeliner eyeshadow I don't know
is it remember lighting the eyes okay
get going I'm just gonna come out of
that I feel like it's just like rubbed
off and nothing came up oh definitely
did
and on watch I guess let's move on to
the website you're gonna look so good in
your teeth sign here
ya think even in front of the look lush
you want to get a lot on there do you
want people to know that you're alive
mmm-hmm okay and you want to put this on
the apples of the cheeks it's very
important that you get it there okay
there you go thank you and go up in
emotion like this it's really gonna make
your face look skinnier and more
prettier um you want to accent it with
blush you want to line
actually this is eyeshadow is it does
that hurt oh okay okay I'm gonna have
more friends than I've ever had probably
oh what's this
we have brushes too somewhere if you can
find them oh we got the brushes we're in
the brush ocular pushes think this is
the bronzer and for bronzer there's a
method called the tea method and you
want to highlight this it's just really
funny tell the little the nose the
bridge of the nose also along the
cheekbones because it makes the face
look slender right now it's really good
a shape your face really nicely I think
that shouldn't do alright next is the
lashes sinker in here Johnny movies
you're not touching glue final dress
okay here we go ready second I
understand oh is that it
it's the other one I want still
oh it's fellow Oh Marco I think we need
to get the glue no I am yeah okay mother
one we'll just do one look that's good
that's good I think it's good do you
think I'm done do you think you're not I
don't know I don't know if I've been
sitting I think you're done okay so they
take links they reveal are you ready
ready so what would it were you thinking
of this Craig felt like you
something
hey guys I'm Mario your skin look my
hair down it actually looks pretty yeah
so I'm not probably never gonna let you
do my makeup question is what do you
guys think oh so now it's my turn to go
to Joey's makeup so check that out oh
are you ready I'm ready let's do this
this is payback
okay before we go - let me show you the
disaster that he made of this make oh my
gosh we got the pull of the pink mess I
think it turned out really good I think
your jaw shovel oh oh you got it I do it
great
I don't want to use that one anymore cuz
I don't want to mix colors let's find
I'm looking for something shiny